you were probably unaware of this little
sort of fringe
uh celebration that's going on right now
but you know in case you missed it
it's pride month yes pride month
the time when every major institution
throughout the entire west bombards you
with radical sexual ideology
that contends that there's a whole group
of oppressed people and we've got to you
know support them they're so oppressed
that every major company in the entire
world
is defending the most radical extremes
of pride ideology so
to celebrate pride month we have to
celebrate we have to have pride
we will be going through the wokest
pride commercials we'll be ranking them
before we get started this video is
sponsored by blinkist which brings you
knowledge from top non-fiction and
podcasts so you can learn anytime
anywhere when even you only have a few
minutes of time more from them later
first
got to get ready this is the liturgical
event of the year in the
liberal liturgical calendar let's check
out
the pride commercials
okay it's foreign so i'm going to
the way i
so the idea is that the little girl the
like five-year-old was a lesbian
[Music]
now that dad's really angry
you're gonna be the one oh and then the
woman gets married but she's a lesbian
she shouldn't have gotten married and
then she
leaves her husband
[Music]
to be with a girl to be with this and
they
have also now i guess have a sort of
daughter somehow
it's it's the renault okay i i want at
least some credit
that it is uh french company i'm glad
that it's foreign at least i couldn't
have guessed that it was a car
i was like what is the around the beach
and there's
because it's french obviously there's a
lot of just gratuitous like kissing and
stuff like that one minute they're
kissing a woman's hand
the necks are chopping off her head
that's not just a lesbian thing
that's just true of all french brands so
it's a car if you
if you want to leave your husband for a
woman and then have a daughter somehow
the only way to do it in style is
driving a renault
okay next one
it's pretty riveting content wow
okay it's like maybe a photographic sort
of company
just let go whatever you think you know
we've been on this earth for a blink of
an eye
how could we expect to understand
everything through the wisdom of the
ages that you just let go of
through like tradition and identity is
not static
[Music]
so much can be broken down and dissolved
it's so beautiful when things get
rebuilt
like a it's a photo thing i guess
like kodiak does kodak even it still
exists magic
full stop it's amazing growing up in
this generation
everything is so fluid
yeah it's got to be a photo thing right
there is history
but at the same time there's also
creating history
i'm doing this even if i don't get to
introduce it like levi's
the only thing is i'm seeing like a
photo thing and like jean jackets
being able to see all of these amazing
people who have been themselves in a
world that's so
not accepting really inspired so not
accepting that every major company is
pushing this stuff for an entire month
yeah it's very not accepting my
liberation
is wrapped up in your liberation
do you think you're afraid well you're
not until i am
i yeah increasingly i think i'm not free
so that we can open ourselves up we're
not free until we trans the kids right
okay
in better relationship with each other
we us did you just assume our pronouns
maybe i identify as she they
i mean i don't know it's like a it is
levi no
way oh my gosh i want credit for that
even though i know i was pushing the
photo thing a long time but i just
something about that jean jacket i was
like okay
that the only other thing i've got is
like levi strauss jeans
wow okay that's good i'm i'm glad that i
got that one false
we've gone from you know when i thought
of levi's i think of like the marlboro
man or
john wayne or somebody you know on the
back of a horse just like talking like
really like a man you know and then but
now it's
quite the opposite of that i wonder if
the village people were kind of the
turning point
because you had like the really manly
like the marlboro man or something then
you got
the village people kind of appropriate
the jean jacket and then now we're
transiting the kids my heroes okay i
love also
this idea to say look let go of
everything you think you know we've been
here for a blink of an eye how do you
think that you can just come up with
everything
and like that is the most conservative
argument i've heard not
they don't have a conservative
conclusion but yeah the argument is
right everything that you've just made
up in your own head
is probably bs and actually it might
behoove you to look at
past generations and what other smarter
people have thought and written in the
past
to know that no you're not a man can't
just become a woman actually i know that
you might think that
because we live in a really weird time
where jeans companies are pushing this
insane ideology
but you can't it's not possible and here
are many reasons why you can read
uh wonderful philosophers on this topic
you can you can look at the philosophies
and heresy's going back
thousands of years or you can watch a
jeans commercial
does it happen to you that you just
don't have time to read
like all of these crazy woke people you
just don't have time to read those books
well instead of having to find the time
to read a whole book always this and
that and the other thing
what if i told you you can listen to all
the highlights in just 15 minutes
blinkist this amazing way to consume
this kind of content saves you time
saves you money allows you to learn new
things faster than ever
blinkist brings you knowledge from top
non-fiction and podcasts
so that you can learn anytime anywhere
blinkist has the best insights from over
4 500
non-fiction books i've got it right here
actually i've got it on my phone
it's incredible because there's some
books where i just i'm going to want to
go right into the book and just read the
whole thing right away but there's some
books where i just kind of want the
highlights right so this one pops up
steve jobs the walter isaacson biography
i don't think i'm ever going to take the
time to go through the whole thing but i
do i do want to
catch something of it oh cool 19 minutes
i can listen to that in 19 minutes
right now the first 100 people to go to
blinkist.com knowles are going to get
unlimited access
for one week to try it out and if books
are only 19 minutes there
you can get through a lot of books in
one week you'll also get 25 off if you
want the full membership the seven-day
trial is completely free
you can cancel at any time during that
period go check out blinkist
all right i'm glad i'm wow guess the
levi's i'm batting
i'm not i would say we're like batting
about 700 now i'm gonna give myself
portions of both of these
no you ain't what's up next
over 500 years ago a navigator led three
ships across the ocean
manned with the toughest cruise three
months after setting sail
they came to an island
this discovery brought about the clash
of two entire civilizations
and provoked what would become the
greatest cultural conflict
in the history of humanity
[Music]
it's hard to say it's not the first time
i guess that we all have our own scars
from the bottles that we've known the
bottles we come from
but it's not all you know i'm gonna say
it's like a deodorant commercial
why i don't i couldn't tell you why
don't you
show me your way it's about to become
a gay thing this is definitely about to
become a gay thing
isn't it
this is now it's kind of like
sacrilegious too
and now the sailors are like really into
this yeah
they you know there's an apocryphal
churchill quote that says the naval
tradition is nothing but rum
sodomy and the lash
now are they all gonna do it
just a giant gay island orgy
with the flag the flag of liberal
imperialism also known as the rainbow
flag
oh that's it is that a chick oh okay
well
[Music]
it's like yes do you know what can bring
together these warring tribes
pure hedonism because
bacchanalian orgies that's what will do
it
i have i have no i can't i have no idea
what this is selling
other than port it's a hotel group
we're hetero friendly you see because
it's
oh gosh axl hotels promotes worldwide
love and respect
all now also in america fine yeah so
of course it's in miami yeah the this
hotel group
promotes um actual orgies which is what
we just saw that's how we'll all come
together
really kind of sacrilegious stuff too
because you see there's the handling of
the crucifix during this and then the
the release of the white dove which is a
symbol of the holy spirit
but they're kind of flipping that on its
head a really creepy stuff because
you know look i've been to a lot of
pretty crazy parties in my life you know
some in hotels even
and uh i've never found that hotel
groups
really encouraged like ragers
and orgies i don't that's not usually
something sometimes
i'll get a noise complaint if i'm like
watching tv too loudly
[Music]
so that's quite a switch i guess we're
seeing a lot of inversions this year all
right axel hotel group if you want to
get up to
get up to that stuff you know then uh
that's
that's the place to go i guess i just
find the whole idea is like we promote
peace and love and joy
i find when you go to like forget even
take the sex stuff out when you go to
just
crazy ragers like wild parties with lots
of people doing lots of
is do you find that's conducive to like
love and peace or do you find i don't
know
to me those get a little a little a
little wild a little
sometimes ugly who knows maybe maybe i'm
just a phobe
maybe i gotta take a stay at the axel
hotel i don't think my wife would like
that
uh please post your other pride month
commercials in the comments section
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you